it is such an honor to welcome governor
Gavin Newsom to Oakland on the 30th
anniversary of the Loma Prieta
earthquake
now I've just come from remembering
those who lost their lives 30 years ago
most of whom were in Oakland in the
Cypress freeway collapse I will never
forget myself coming home that night to
my apartment where every single window
was shattered and there was a crack in
my wall so large I could see Lake
Merritt through it and as the horror
dawned that so many people had lost
their lives that so much damage was done
to this Bay Area it was a sobering
experience and yet we saw how Oakland
came together today I am so thrilled to
be here as the backdrop to this
announcement that will help all
Californians be safer second save lives
early warning can allow people
incredible opportunity to prepare to
cover their heads with the pillows to
duck and roll to avoid more catastrophic
loss like was experienced 30 years ago
and it is a supreme pleasure to
introduce leadership in California that
is investing in this type of preventive
technology before the next big one
happens all of California is safer today
because of this incredible
groundbreaking announcement and so with
that it is my pleasure to introduce to
you a governor who has demonstrated a
bold vision and a willingness to invest
in prevention so that we do not have as
much tragedy and destruction to deal
with after the next big one that we know
is inevitable governor Gavin Newsom
Thank you Thank You mayor for I've never
been on this this remarkably new cuz
this is fabulous and by the way for all
those folks that only watch I say this
lovingly and
spec fillet I'm one of them but not only
watch fox news that's not the picture
you get a San Francisco every night on
your television screen I just want to
remind people what a spectacular place
this is the San Francisco Bay Area the
Oakland Bay Area the San Jose Bay Area
how vibrant it is and how remarkable how
remarkably well this region is doing and
it is appropriate that we are here in
this region on this day an anniversary
30 years from Loma Prieta earthquake
like mayor Chef I among many many that
are assembled here today was in my
apartment about to walk out a little
late to watch the World Series at a
friend's house at 15 Rico Way in the
Marina District when all of a sudden I
felt the shaking and the old chandelier
going back and forth I naively the time
I think they told you to go under the
door
now they say drop cover hold but the
time it was going to the door and I
remember going back and forth and
hearing car alarms and the day go off
and walked outside and didn't know what
the heck would happen I thought the
sewage system said all bursts was that
thing we learned afterwards called
liquefaction that was coming up
something people had predicted but
they'd never seen in the scale and scope
just a block and a half away were those
was that iconic building lives were lost
that had collapsed that corner building
in the marina district and everybody was
assembled to help out it's a moment of
pride in spirit not just tragedy to see
neighbors folks from all walks of life
coming together to help one another and
I say that in that spirit of resilience
the spirit that defines the best of this
region finds the best of a city San
Francisco that was ravaged by not just
the 89 earthquake but the 1906
earthquake they remind folks the the
flag the icon on the flag of San
Francisco is the phoenix phoenix rising
from the ashes of the earthquake and so
we are cognizant of not only this moment
as we reflect on history and our past
but we look
to the future a few years back a lot of
you ran with headlines saying that
experts had put out a prediction 99.7%
chance within the next thirty years
ninety nine point seven percent chance
within the next thirty years we would
experience an earthquake greater than
six point seven it was a rather
jaw-dropping prediction particularly
from experts that are cautious in making
those types of predictions that's the
reality we live in there's a reason we
experience and enjoy such beauty and
that's Mother Nature with all her glory
but at times her fury so the price of
admission to live here is preparation
that price is paid often by neglect lack
of preparation lack of intentionality as
it relates to making sure that we are
prepared to support one another our
families ourselves in a time of crisis
today we are making a big leap forward
in terms of focusing attention on
prevention we are announcing the
nation's first comprehensive early alert
system for earthquakes we're announcing
the ability for millions and millions of
Californians to download an app my shake
download the app my shake millions of
people do that we will have points of
contact the ability to crowdsource
information the likes of which no
country in the world has advanced I say
that knowingly that Japan and Mexico
have systems already in place in this
space but because of the extraordinary
complementary work that was done by UC
Berkeley by Caltech by USGS and by our
own office of emergency service we feel
we are on the leading and cutting edge
in terms of the ability to utilize this
technology but it is only as good as you
you download that app we now have
another point of contact and we are now
all part of this remarkable
chasity to iterate to experiment to
advance science in real-time to make us
all more safe and so I just cannot
impress upon folks more the importance
of going to the App Store
whatever their device may be downloading
my shake and reading the instructions
and encouraging friends and family to do
the same this is about 10 seconds it's
about 15 seconds this could be as much
as 20 seconds of early warning in 20
seconds that's a not an insignificant
amount of time to make sure we shut down
or slow down the BART make sure we slow
down or shut down an elevator make sure
we open an elevator door or open
emergency doors or or fire station
garage doors to make sure that we turn
off equipment we are talking to Senator
Hill a moment ago he says if you're you
know going to an optometrist and they've
got a laser in your eye to turn the
laser off before the procedure to make
sure that we take care of those that are
most in need to take care of the most
acute facilities be it you know an old
refinery natural gas facility to make
sure we shut off I para love saying this
the transmission line in anticipation I
know you'll probably run with that so I
know that I walked into it but it is one
of the benefits of this system that the
utilities are connected to this system
in an earthquake that could prevent a
lot of lives and a lot of property
damage from occurring